But isn't it on America and wrong to
discriminate against people based on
their religion?
Really the problem.
We have people coming into our country
that are looking to do tremendous harm.
You look at the t,
look at Paris,
look at what happened in Paris.
I mean these people,
they did not come from Sweden.
Okay?
Look at what happened in Paris.
Look at what happened last week in
California with with 14 people dead.
Other people going to die there so badly
injured mean we have a real problem.
There's a tremendous hatred out there
and what I want to do is find out what
you know.
You can't solve a problem until you find
out what's the root core cars and I want
to find out what is the problem,
what's going on?
And it's temporary.
I've had so many people call me and say
thank you.
Now,
if you remember when I did that a week
ago,
it was like bedlam all of a sudden and
you watched last night and you see
people talking to say,
well,
trump has a point.
We have to get down to the problem.
The people that are friends of mine,
they called,
they said,
Donald,
you've done us a tremendous service
because we do have a problem and we have
to find out those crank calls.
Those may have been.
Yeah,
great.
One of the things I find fascinating
about Donald Trump is the way he uses
language differently than other
candidates for political office,
especially for president of the United
States.
Whereas his opponents and the political
class in general seem hyper aware that
their words will be picked apart and
used against them.
Trump willfully disregards this fact as
a lifelong salesman,
he has a hucksters knack for selling the
feeling,
even if the ideas and facts that
underscore it are spurious racist or
just plain incomprehensible.
So I thought it would be illuminating to
look at a trump answer to a simple
question.
In this case,
Jimmy Kimmel asking trump whether or not
it's wrong to discriminate against
people based on their religion,
referring to trump's proposal to
temporarily ban all Muslims from
entering the United States.
This 220 word,
exactly one minute answer displays.
I think a range of the things that trump
uses all the time in his speech,
the first thing to note is how simple
this languages of the 220 words,
a 172 or 78 percent are only one
syllable,
and often they come in a rhythmic series
like a volley of Jabs,
ending with one of his buzzwords.
We have to get down to the prop.
Thirty nine words or 17 percent are two
syllables long.
Only four words have three syllables,
three of which are the word.
Tremendous,
tremendous,
and just two words are four syllables
long,
California,
which he's forced to use because it has
less syllables than San Bernardino and
temporary,
which he swallows and it's temporary.
I've had so many people just breakdown
fits with the study done by the Boston
Globe that put all 2016 presidential
candidates announcement speeches through
the flesh,
kincade readability tests to determine
their respective grade level rankings.
Donald Trump's speech came out at a
fourth grade reading level.
Now for reference,
Ben Carson came out at sixth grade.
Hillary Clinton and Jeb Bush were
speaking at an eighth grade reading
level,
and Bernie Sanders was way up in high
school,
a sophomore to be exact.
Now,
this isn't only down to word or syllable
choice.
It's about sentence construction to
trump favors simple sentences like,
and we have a real problem.
There's a tremendous hatred out there.
Rarely does he use complex sentences or
independent clauses.
You also favors the second person.
A lot of time addressing listeners
directly with commands.
Look at Paris,
look at what happened in Paris.
Look at what happened in past.
Look at what happened last week in
California or implicating us in what
he's saying as if we've already agreed
and you watched last night and you see
people talking.
He's really good at this at framing
negative response as an overreaction.
That was subsequently realized as such.
If you remember when I did that a week
ago,
it was like bedlam all of a sudden and
you watch last night and you see people
talking to say,
well,
trump has a point.
We have to get down to the problem.
Maybe the most important technique trump
utilizes and he does this more than
anyone I've ever heard,
is ending his sentences with strong,
punchy words.
A lot of times he'll rearrange the
beginning of a sentence awkwardly so
that he can end strong.
For example,
here,
it would probably be more natural to say
you can't solve a problem until you find
out what the root cause is,
but he brings the is forward to end on
root cause.
He does the same here and it looks like
that's what he was about to do at the
end before Kim will cut some off.
These final words are crucial for trump.
They're pointed and taken together.
Sketch the theme of the entire answer
are dead.
Die Badly injured problem root cars.
Thank you Edna Bravo service problem.
In some sense,
it's these words that audiences
remember,
especially when the rest of his speech
is incoherent.
Like the best salesman.
Trump keeps it simple.
He repeats a lot and we have a real
problem.
What is the problem?
We do have a problem.
We have to get down to the problem and
he uses his favorite words over and
over,
tremendous,
tremendous service,
and he always seems to have friends who
are part of the group that he's
currently insulting.
Calling him up and thanking him for the
privilege.
Many of them called me and they said,
you know,
Donald,
you're right.
We have a problem.
Look,
there is a problem.
Donald trump knows when to sound
incredulous or forceful.
He has good comedic instinct.
You could even call him woody,
but you can't call him smart,
are well informed.
The best salesman could sell you a TV
without knowing anything about it
because the TV isn't what matters.
What matters is you,
and if you are an American citizen who
for years has listened to politicians
sound sophisticated while accomplishing
nothing,
you might just be primed for something
that is everything they are not,
but the next time you feel like Donald
trump has a point,
do yourself a favor and look at his
words.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
I want to point you in the direction of
my friends over at wisecrack who do some
awesome work.
Some awesome video essays.
Um,
if you like my stuff,
you're definitely gonna like what they
do.
They talk about books,
movies,
and my personal favorite is definitely a
bit philosophy,
which is like philosophy explained with
Nintendo graphics.
So.
Well done.
I wish I'd thought of that.
Um,
anyway,
go over there.
Click there,
subscribe,
watch a video.
If you guys want to help me out as
always,
you can click right here.
Pledge a dollar or $3 or $5 to my
channel.
Help me start 2016.
Right?
We're going to do some awesome stuff in
the next year.
I can't wait to see you guys next
Wednesday for the next video and I will
see you.
Well,
I just said I'm gonna.
See you next Wednesday.
So by.